alright looks like we have a pretty good
crowd tonight we got some some new faces
we got some staff here so we're looking
pretty good in tonight let's see I
wanted to give credit to the people that
suggested the opening so for my car JB
and Jonathan Morales who wanted to see
the Scandinavian defense this episode is
for you and there were many others so
when I see the same openings over and
over I can't help but pick it for my
lecture so okay this is chess openings
explained I'm Johnathan Schwantz and
today we're going to look at a very
controversial opening now last week
you'll remember I was kind of joking
about it
I had my box I was placing things into
different categories certain openings
were solid certain openings were sharp
certain openings were suspicious and it
was hard where do you categorize this
opening here we see a very violent and
aggressive move already on move one from
black he immediately contests the e4
pawn with the move to d5 so so what is
this is it suspicious that's what the
general consensus was but there's a lot
of people to think of it as a solid
opening some people think of it as a
sharp opening and really it's a little
bit of both so obviously why would
somebody even consider doing this
knowing that after the pawn takes which
is the overwhelmingly popular move here
in after okay you can play Knight f6 but
today we're going to look at the main
line with our Queen takes and so why
would somebody do this if you're you
know a beginner this isn't this break
one of the the very first beginner rules
that you know don't bring your your
queen out too early don't move your
pieces twice in the opening and yet here
black is tempting white to play the move
Knight to c3 and kick the Queen away so
why would somebody ever want to play
this well for black he's thinking in a
lot of cases he can get an improved
caro-kann and we'll look at that when we
get to the main line okay he's thinking
all right well this Bishop gets to get
out for free
I'm going to set up my ponds ins a nice
solid fashion and I'm gonna hope for a
solid position and if white doesn't play
very accurately doesn't play actively
enough I'm going to get a very nice
solid position and so that's a the one
argument you might have for why this is
a solid opening also it's it's obviously
there is some suspicion you're moving
your queen around a lot and so white is
going to try to take advantage of this
in this opening he's going to try to get
all these pieces out as quickly as
possible and exploit the fact that the
Queen has made a couple moves in the
opening in black is behind in
development and okay we'll see that the
strategies as we go along here so black
has to move as Queen and there's two
main moves here the first one which is
still arguably the main line although
also popular still is a queen to d6 this
is quickly becoming one of the most
popular variations and there are some
others that we'll explore but knowing
Ben Simon he'll cut all that out you got
to be here live to see those because
he's lazy like it's too long you know
this is gonna be a three-hour lecture so
so brace yourselves it won't be that
long but alright so we're going to look
at Queen to a5 first which for the
longest time was the main line so and
it's it's still very popular today and
so okay how should I proceed there's a
there's a lot of different ways the most
common here is just to play d4 and so
kind of the point of what black has done
so far as he's prevented white from
getting the pawn duo with his pawns on
c4 and d4 and as we'll see if black has
his pawn set up here white is going to
be trying to play the pawn break d5
breaking open the position and if you
had a pawn on c4 that would be much
easier but since you put a knight on c3
you gain some time but uh alright also
you put a knight in front of your pawn
that they might want to move alright
so black makes a normal developing move
and then white also the the main line is
just to move his knight out which of
course looks like a logical move but
it's not the only move here you can
consider Bishop to c4 you consider
Bishop to d2 and those have their
purposes as well you're just trying to
get to move d5 in this
quickly as possible but Knight f3 also
has its appeal in a lot of lines you're
going to go to e5 and play a quick g4 g5
and we'll understand why in a little bit
here okay
now black has to be careful of his queen
he needs to make sure he always has a
retreat square at some point there's
gonna be a bishop going to d2 and the
night will be threatening discoveries so
c6 is sort of essential to Black's plan
he knows that's how he's going to set up
his pawns anyway and now his queen can
retreat usually to c7 so he's got some
access to retreat if he ever needs to
know White will get his Bishop out again
another move that's fighting for the d5
square and it's time for black to get
his Bishop out normally in the
Scandinavian just as a general guideline
you're going to get your LightSquared
Bishop out first and your dark squared
Bishop out second and the reason is
you're going to put a pawn on e6 and you
don't want your bishop trapped behind
your your wall of pawns
so there's two logical options Bishop to
f5 is the most common so that's what
you'll will be looking at there is
something to be said about Bishop to g4
although these lines are very very sharp
so White has no problem here playing h3
trying to win the bishop pair and but
most people will retreat to h5 not
wanting to give up control of the light
squares although we if you're you were
watching there was a blitz game between
Cara Juana and Carlsen from last year
2015 and Carlsen took here which seems
to be his preferred way to play these
situations and I white followed up by
taking with the Queen and now White has
the two bishops and he does get a very
pleasant position and we'll see in
another game at least okay so normally
they retreat and these are actually very
very sharp lines now we've had
Grandmaster Ian Rogers here doing lots
of commentary for us and he's by far
played this the most in database that I
have you see his name at the top for all
of the the games in this variation and
black has to be really careful so if you
do want to play this you should know
what you're doing White's next few
hooves are going to be g-49 to e5 he's
going to end up putting his bishop here
and his queen is going to protect the e4
square so that he can if the bishop is
here he can you know he's going to play
h4 h5 he's going to try to trap that
Bishop and it since we haven't castled
over there yet a move like g4 is is
totally not out of the question followed
by a quick Knight to e5 and that's also
a very common theme in this opening the
theme of the Bishop hunt white is often
going after this LightSquared Bishop so
we're going to see a lot of that today
okay so more popular is Bishop to f5 and
if you play the Scandinavian regularly
that's almost always where you put your
Bishop and your follow up is going to be
the movie six all right so what is still
thinking about how he can make the d5
brake work so he plays Bishop to d2
which is usually a prerequisite to
playing d5 for this this recipe to work
there's generally three key ingredients
that you need to play a successful d5
pawn break one of those is you need to
have a bishop on d2 so that you can do
discoveries on the Queen and gain a free
move with your knight
another thing that's really important is
that the black king is still in the
center it'll be a lot more effective if
you're opening the center and exploiting
the fact that black hasn't developed all
of his pieces yet as the king is there
and importantly your other LightSquared
Bishop he needs to be protected as well
usually by the move Queen to e2 which
not only protects the bishop it also
puts a lot of pressure on the e-file so
these these three key ingredients are
what we need and so the move Bishop to
d2 that gets one of them the King's
already here so next we're going to try
to protect our Bishop with Queen e2 so
it's kind of mandatory for black to play
a six here and it's it's important to
kind of show why if you play a little
bit carelessly a seemingly normal
development move you actually can be in
a lot of trouble already and in this
position black is already flirting with
having a lost position so after Queen e2
now
we have everything that we need for the
d5 break to work we can see in this
position d5 is actually really crushing
and we'll look at why if black takes and
he probably should Knight takes d5 this
was the point so we got an attack on the
Queen so she's going to have to move
back and one of the biggest problems for
black is the open D file which you know
can really be a headache and we'll see
so the Queen has to retreat and now the
move the white plays as he takes the
knight and there's not a comfortable way
for blacks to take back if he takes back
with the knight this is the easiest move
to refute you have the move Bishop to b5
and you know if you block then you're
just blundering this piece so that move
is definitely out
so yeah the most common is taking with a
pawn we'll look briefly at taking with
the Queen but this might be a little bit
too many Queen moves you know you've you
can't just move your queen around the
whole time you're you're probably you
might be thinking about taking on b2 but
here after the move castling queenside
white already has a really big threat
and the threat is Bishop to g5 following
by the sacrifice on d7 to illustrate
this point we'll go a couple moves
further now black has a really cute move
here I don't say it's the best but it's
it's kind of funny you can play Bishop
to a3 and the point is if we take this
Bishop what's blacks next move it seems
like D seems like the audience tonight
can probably figure this one out
Queen a1 and that's yeah a funny
checkmate this would have been in my
commerce lecture about funny checkmates
so alright that's not what happened
and this is a game that this is actually
been played about four times so people
do get into trouble here so after c3 now
your you might be threatening to take
the bishop and if you play a careless
move you should you should probably
retreat the Queen with the same idea
that if you take there's also a
checkmate don't forget about the bishop
but a careless move and the game would
already be over now you can play Bishop
to g5 winning a tempo on the Queen she
only has one square she can go to where
she's safe and now you can take this
knight and black should either castle
here or resign because if you take the
rook there's this really nasty fork so
yeah not not the best so you can see
that does get you into a lot of trouble
if you take with the Queen it's also
there are some issues if you take with
the pawn white will play the same at the
beginning he's going to Castle queenside
and he's going to make some pretty
serious threats so let's see there was a
game and this is the game
Petrosian winter which was the
highest-rated game I could find from
this position and a6 was played it's not
a whole lot different if you just you
develop your queen but that also was a
possible continuation but after a6 like
got a crushing position after the move
Knight to d4 threatening to take the
bishop which would just win a piece
because there there's a pin here so
white is just going to try to take the
bishop if you drop back we're thinking
about some sacrifices here these
sacrifices don't quite work immediately
but in this game after white plays the
move f4 now he's getting really serious
he's playing f5 next which will crush
black and after the move Bishop to c5 in
the game white played Bishop to c3 but
now the sacrifice does work you can take
here and this would just crush black so
you did give up a piece well you have a
lot of nasty discoveries this queen is
looking really good your rook is really
good it's easy to find a good square for
this piece so if black blocks for
example white can win a piece back with
your taking and after this move you lose
a piece it is a discovered check and
whatever happens you you win a piece
here so this would be a fantastic win
for white so you can really see the
dangers of the d5 break that something
black has to really be
alert for because that can end your game
immediately so it is it is a rather
sharp opening sometimes and black does
have to be extra-careful that's why II
six is necessary here and now we reach
sort of a branch in the tree there's two
main moves here for white the most
common is it I mean at least now in a
modern opening theory here
Knight to d5 which has overtaken the
previous Queen to e2 now before I did
this lecture I was only familiar with
some of this theory but then you look in
the database and you look at this
position I did the top 14 games by
rating of the white player and they all
played Knight to d5 which is something
really strange normally you know a lot
of people will be playing it but not
everybody but it seems like everybody at
the top these days is playing Knight to
d5 so that's going to be our main line
for tonight and it is probably the most
critical attempt for an advantage as
white to give you a sense of what's
going on here so you're you're trying to
make this this work you protected it we
again we got our our key ingredients
we're ready to play d5 so if black is a
little bit too greedy he actually can
get into a lot of trouble immediately
because now the move d5 comes and if you
take before we take back on d5 we can
toss in this check and now black is in a
lot of trouble so even if he retreats
because we were attacking the Queen with
our Bishop there's no real good defense
here after the move Bishop to c3 the
problem is we're attacking your Bishop
and if it retreats we're ready to bring
a rook into d1 now black and hope that
he can play the move e5 and protect his
Knight that's his only hope even though
II five is not the move you want to play
but you got to try to save your Bishop
but white can stop him just Knight h4
and if your bishop retreats weep in the
night and we just we're going to pick up
a piece here and the King is in a lot of
danger so again yeah d5 is the
the key tactical point in all of these
variations so instead the move black
should play here is Bishop to b4 and so
this is the old line now after in just a
minute we're going to get to play a3 win
the bishop pair and force the queen to
retreat so I would black really want to
play this way because it looks like
alright why it's got the two bishops
which is really nice and what does black
have William almost all positions in the
Scandinavian black is playing for
dynamic and active piece play so he's
hoping at some point to maneuver one of
his knights to the d5 square he would
love to trade these guys off so that d5
could be his square nice home for one of
his knights and he would really like to
play against a dark squared Bishop and
we'll see even in the main line he does
get a lot of activity so I have to
remove like Knight to e5 which is
typically where the Knights going to go
in these variations and occasionally
white is thinking about you know
attacking and getting a pawn storm on
the Kings side black has to decide
should I take on e5 or not and more
often than not in this opening they do
end up taking but you do need to be kind
of careful because this pawn at least in
the middle game should be a pretty
strong asset for white but the point
here of his play was ah he has time you
know white doesn't ever get access into
d6 because he's going to plug a knight
in to d5 and threaten to take away
White's big advantage which is the
bishop pair which is why most people
will retreat the bishop to d2 and even
though d2 isn't the optimal square for a
bishop we saw this so fans of our
YouTube channel might know if you saw
Eric Hanson's lessons on how to use the
two bishops sometimes you save your
bishop you go to d2 and later it will
reimburse as a stronger piece so now
black has time to Castle and just to go
a little bit farther so you can see why
people may have stopped playing this
line the main continuation is g4 an f4
with the plan of trying to trap this
Bishop which
you know a huge theme in these openings
Rana we're on a Bishop hunt here so what
should black do well and when you play
g4 usually he should play the move h5
and we'll see why that's important for
him in just a second because after the
Queen starts to get active another
common maneuver is getting the Queen to
c5 or you know and sometimes opening up
the C file if you could get rid of your
C pawn the Queen is usually pretty nice
here on the C file and black will get a
lot of pressure on the pawn after rook
to f1 we can see why the move h5 was
played now the rook gets access along
the H file so after we we play here the
route can come down to h3 threatening to
win this Bishop due to the pin now it's
a funny mistake would be king to b1
forgetting about the other bishop which
would be a big mistake
so you have to do something about it the
rook on h3 is just so active you got to
try to trade it off and to take that
main line to its its conclusion here you
get such a position where yes White has
two bishops but the active play of black
here really you know can't be denied so
I assume if you pulled a lot of strong
players there'd be mixed feelings over
who would want to be better here wait if
he does have an advantage it's only
really small and the active pieces that
black has is exactly what you're trying
to get when you play the Scandinavian so
I think both sides would be happy here
but this isn't the most critical
continuation so we'll go back for just a
second
okay so we'll look not at Queen to e2
we'll look briefly now at the main line
Knight to d5 so again we have our
discovered attack it's it's a simpler
move we're not going for an immediate d5
necessarily though it might come in some
certain variations but after this move
again we take the knight and the main
line is to take back with a pond so our
first game that we look at today that's
what we're going to look at again you
can get into a little bit of trouble if
you take with the Queen though this is a
normal enough variation and what is
again going to think about how to play
the move d5 you do sometimes have to
worry about this pawn so but not not
immediately because if you do take again
you're going to play the move d5 and all
right after that we get these lines in
this was blacks key maneuver bringing a
knight over to d5 but all right so if
white does get d5 in he's usually doing
pretty good and there's there's more
than one move here you can take black
should also consider the line with
Bishop takes c2 this is just to give you
an example because this isn't our focus
of the lecture rook takes d5 is one of
the key points so what if we take this
rook what is white playing here
will notice the strength of this Bishop
restricting a lot of squares that the
King can go to the only squares we're
not attacking are some of these light
squares Queen a for a slight inaccuracy
because I I have a legal move I can
block yeah it's actually mating one if
you go to b5 but yeah but if you want to
torture your opponent just a little bit
you know you wanna you want to play I'll
let you live one more move and then I'll
checkmate you that'd be that'd be funny
but black has a clever way out of this
though it's not the greatest and if you
take the bishop now we can take your
rook because if you check us we're going
to just grab the bishop here so you
should move the Queen and protect your
bishop and this is very very pleasant
for white black can threaten checkmate
but White has a very nice way to defend
against this Knight to d4 and excellent
square for the knight and okay this is
sort of the best possible variation for
black and after f4 though white is just
crushing black here the move f5 is
coming
you can't castle so it's hard to use
your rook over here if you can't castle
and white just has tremendous pressure
so this would be an example of how not
to play as black okay so we're going to
go back and before we look at our first
game I want to briefly go over a common
opening that gets the same pawn
structure as we'll see in our mainline
when you play the caro-kann occasionally
you get this variation so this is all
common and we did a lecture before I'm
Bishop to c5 the classical line but
after the move Knight to f6 which is a
really dynamic and fighting way to play
as black black can take here and now we
have the Bronstein Larsen variation and
here black is trying to play four really
active and dynamic play he's hoping to
make use of the G file
and okay here none of the pieces have
been developed but if you reach this
position from a Scandinavian move order
the the pieces you've already got your
bishop out here and you the pawn will be
here we can imagine White's already got
his pieces out the bishops on d2 which
is obviously not a move you would
consider in this position so white will
have to spend a move to correct that and
this is the big argument when you're
playing the Scandinavian is this
variation that we're going to reach and
we can we can jump back to it we'll see
it in a second with all the pieces where
they are is it better for black or is it
better for white in this position here
so okay and it's it's a really good good
debate one thing is in this position the
main move is c3 so white can say well
you don't get this variation I already
got my knight on f3 and you've already
spent a move playing Bishop to f5 and
black and say okay but you you put your
Bishop on d2 which is which would be
silly to do in this position so let's
jump right into our first game here
alright this is the game between Ruslan
ponomaryov and a guy whose name I'm
going to try to pronounce but I really
have no chance these Greek players are
pretty tough for me
Yoenis papaya no I'm sure I got that
completely wrong so if you're a Greek
feel free to make fun of me in the
comments and we're going to look at this
the main line was was played here
alright we got the Queen to a5 variation
and play continues as normal and we get
the Knight to d5 variation so after the
retreat not taking with the Queen we
take with the ponds and again we get the
same pawn structure as we saw when we
looked at the caro-kann line and so
that's the big question
who does that help more as a black or
black or white and that's what the rest
of the game will will determine now
white yeah at least to get a little bit
more out of the opening he's trying to
again put his Queen on e2 thinking about
playing the d5 break also potentially
occasionally he has this break
but probably not in this game if you
play Queen to e to the C pawn might be
hanging here so it's probably best to
protect it sometimes they play the move
c3 which does give away the d3 square
occasionally if this Knight moves away
so the the most solid way for black for
white to play is Bishop to b3 just
getting ready to play Queen to e2 and
we'll make a few more normal moves and
now we'll try to understand what are the
themes why why are you know what are
both sides trying to accomplish here
what is the plan for black what's the
plan for white black is hoping for some
really dynamic play he's banging white
to Castle kingside then okay this plan
would be really obviously get a lot of
pressure along the G file so probably
why it's going to castle on the Queen
side black is not going to castle on the
King side because of his pawn structure
over here so both of the Kings are going
to end up over on the Queen side and
then the biggest plan for white is he's
going to try to go on a bishop hunt so
we're going to look at that and black
will get active play if you ever can
play the break c5 and get some pressure
along the C file after the king is
castled he's going to be on c1 so
black's going to play c5 opened up the
game and trying to get really active
pieces so the way to go after the bishop
is to attack it now you're threatening
to win the bishop so the bishop would
have to retreat and wait here can make
an interesting decision probably it's
not the best to take the bishop here
though that is one idea and even though
black ends up with what i like to call
the tetris pawn formation because it
looks a lot more like a Tetris piece
than it does a pawn structure that you
see in the books it does actually give
black a lot of control especially of the
fifth rank here the pawns are just
really dominant not giving white any
entrance and the fact that this bishop
is looking into a wall is you know
pretty a pretty good feature for black
and in the future black will think about
trading off the dark squared bishop s'
which will be in his best interest and
he's going to try to
have a night against a bishop and try to
prove that since your Bishop is stuck
against the wall I can find a better
square for my knight than you can find
for your bishop so all right so in that
game it wasn't chosen White has another
plan for trying to hunt down that Bishop
he needs to get his knight out of the
way so he can play h4 h5 and the way
that he does this after both sides
castle is g3 the plan is to rima new ver
the Knight to f4 and play h4 h5 and try
to trap the bishop here black just
waited he made a nice waiting move so
that now when he plays c5 his King is a
little bit more tucked in and even you
know the rook will sometimes be able to
come over to the C file if he gets a
nice C file attack so just a normal move
and we see the knight maneuver okay so
what is black going to do he probably
can start thinking about playing c5 here
in this game Bishop d6 was played which
is okay but it's you know you could
probably spend the tempo a little bit
better and just get on with with your
pressure here and white plays h4
threatening to trap the bishop so if I
if I blunder with black and I just I
just wait just show we're trapping this
bishop he only has one safe square and
now he has zero safe squares so this is
our focus so we're we're forcing black
here to play the move
h5 and now we're going after the bishop
we're threatening to take the bishop and
if you take back your your e pawn is
falling I got two pieces that can take
your EEP on so what happened in this
game is black decided to sacrifice a
pawn which is very typical in this line
and after white takes black is saying my
attack after I'm getting c5 in is going
to be quite strong I'm going to get a
lot of pressure that's why I sacrificed
a pond and oK you've spent some time
maneuvering your knight around just to
win upon
so after c5 white here played a nice
attacking move all right g4 and now
black played a move that will shock the
audience rook takes Knight okay so it is
an exchange sacrifice he's using the one
piece that really isn't involved in the
attack on the king and okay you gave it
up for the night hoping for some active
play if you take the rook in this
position has been played about eight
times and everybody has taken the bishop
so it is interesting to ask what happens
if we take the row
well now black will get a lot of
activity after he takes on d4 and his
compensation really is in the form of
the attack on the C pawn and the fact
that these pawns are a little bit weaker
than they are in the game that we'll see
because okay there's a pawn in front of
the other pond which makes it harder for
you to promote in the future because you
don't have a rook to support your
advances and play might continue since
this has never been played the computer
would like you to play King to be won in
black it's lots of compensation after
threatening to skewer the Queen and rook
so you play a defensive move black can
gang up on the C to pawn what can defend
but here black obviously has a lot of
activity for the exchange in the future
you can solidify his pawns in the center
he can take the fish up whenever he
feels like it and just a constant
pressure here on c2 makes life for white
really difficult so all right so that's
why in the game ponomaryov
decided to take the bishop and not allow
him to have all that active play
so here material is equal but what is
content with his his past H pawn and so
in the future he'll start pushing that
guy down the board all right now right
so yeah black was about to take on d4 so
now if you take on d4 I can take back
with a bishop and here black makes sort
of the big mistake that hurt him in the
long run he tried to exchange the big
chubs which is a mistake because if you
exchange all of the pieces the endgame
is going to be winning for white this
pawn is very strong so the more pieces
that are exchanged the better this is
going to be for white so what we saw was
a liquidation of lots and lots of pieces
and then an aged pawn that starts to go
up the board and after we get the Queens
off white now has a completely winning
endgame so black really made miss played
that middle game he needed to keep all
of the pieces on the board because his
that was his big trump was as active
pieces and his dynamic play and this
often happens when you have a dynamic
position and then everything gets
liquidated suddenly or you realize
you're lost Black has to get back to
stop the pawn and white advances this
King to the center this is an opening
class so we're not going to focus on the
technique here but argh a white if you
can get his King over to h5 he'd be
looking pretty good because then he gets
his rook over here and yeah so this this
is a not the best rook here the activity
if the rook and the King are much better
than blacks so black really is no no
chance here okay it was pretty nice
technique and now I quite like the last
move - it's just a simple move b5 and
black resigned the point is if you take
I can check I can bring my rook back
here and then I have to pass pawns which
is too many for black to deal with so a
really nice game played by white he you
know he went on the Bishop hunt and his
opponent liquidated all the pieces so he
ended up in a winning endgame we're
going to look at one more game today in
this time we'll even let black be the
hero and we'll look at a slightly
different variation so we kind of looked
at Queen to a5 now we're going to look
at Queen to d6 which is also
you know potentially some people might
consider this the new main line but at
Queen to a5 still very popular it should
be mentioned that there's two other
queen moves one of those is a Queen to
d8 which I like only because it follows
my rule I always play Queen to d8 this
position though it never really has had
a good reputation well because you know
you've wasted a lot of time right now
just gets to make a developing move and
get on with things and you've got a lot
of work to do to get your pieces out to
active squares but now there's not going
to be any discoveries on your queen
she's safe she's back at home and this
was even played last year between
Carlsen and Cara Juana in a rapid game
and okay in this game Carlsen with the
black pieces he seems to like to put his
Bishop on g4 and take the knight on f3
so most you know grandmasters frown on
this but he's the world champion and
that seems to be his plan every game so
yeah so protecting the b-pawn and late
to e2 was played in this game which will
just we'll go over briefly it's
interesting he's going to put his bishop
on g2 so the Knights not really boxing
in the bishop so that's an interesting
way of protecting the D pawn black tries
to trade Queens white decides to keep
the Queen's on the board which is a good
decision but now a pesky little move
attacking the C pawn trying to provoke
some weaknesses and here white actually
has a very pleasant position the opening
of the a file is quite nice for him he
got to take back towards the center he's
got two bishops and well it is kind of a
suspicious variation so white ended up
with a good position but Carlson's
technique here I was just simply better
than his opponents he got ready to
Castle queenside and now so okay he's
maneuvering his knight and this is a
really nice move he's planning on
trading the dark squared bishop here and
we'll see what he does with the dark
squares so we can see in this variation
he's provoked some some weaknesses here
he's going to jump a knight in
and yeah we're not really covering this
line in detail today but just to give
you an idea of this this game there was
really nice that I remember watching it
was it was a good one
and here he got a a weakness that he's
going to go take advantage of later and
it's just nice technique here he
provoked c5 and then he just put his
knight back in the hole so after white
tooks now black has a passed pawn white
has some weaknesses and he was able to
exploit them now he's winning upon soon
he's going to win more and okay so black
is now just just winning and okay so we
saw after this trade a technically
winning endgame and so Karl wanna
resigned here all right so that's that's
that variation there is one more move
that's even more suspicious Queen d8 is
you know kind of playable but there is
also the Patzer variation based on the
joke Patzer sees a Czech Patzer plays a
Czech you can you know this probably is
not the best Queen move although it is
very hard to refute I like to think of
this opening as the john-boy or opening
because he plays it sometimes and it is
kind of funny you play see six this is
the point you get to retreat and white
gets a lot of pieces out really quickly
and gets you know a very pleasant
position but it is very difficult to
prove that you've refuted this based on
the fact that you know black will try to
play as solidly as possible and just to
take the line a little farther to see
how white might get a good attack this
is actually the game now where Cara
Juana is white again so he seems to to
get this a lot and let's see where is it
who was he playing he's playing cooler
holes
another name I'm probably mispronouncing
who was 2266 at the time of this game so
he's playing with the black pieces in
Cara Juana is going to win with the
white pieces here just to give you a
little idea little introduction to this
and because this is extra long Ben
Simon's cutting all of this out that's
now you know No all right good good the
people need to see it
so this was probably the first
inaccuracy from white the computers
wanted you to keep your Bishop on e 2 so
you could quickly you know advance your
your F pawn but still very pleasant for
for the white player the Knights going
to jump in to c5 and now let's just ask
some big problems here and black
blundered in this position one of the
big problems is this Knight is the only
defender that's preventing you from
forking the rook and the Queen and you
can actually attack it with tempo
because you attack the bishop first and
then you attack the knight and now black
us in trouble
so here you could go in for the fork but
he plays an even stronger move c4 and
yeah now the night goes on a little
journey into White's camp and it's very
unusual to see an item b1 and here white
is winning material so the game ended
quickly after this move the threat of
Knight to e5 with more pressure on the
pin piece and the fact that you're
already down material and you're losing
more made black give it up here so now
on to our our next featured game okay so
onto Queen d6
which is becoming a very popular move
we'll we'll see white do sort of the
same thing and we'll see black go for a
slightly different plan in this position
a six now in this variation what
typically happens is he's trying to play
the move b5 and Bishop to b7 which we
didn't see in the other lines so a6 is
useful not just because it controls b5
and so not White's not going to put a
piece there but at the move b5 is sort
of a a good variation for black so white
- you know refute this plays g3 and gets
his Bishop on the long diagonal in now
black is best devised to find a
different approach if you play b5 here
for example white tends to get a very
good position after some some normal
moves and now Knight to e5 trading the
LightSquared Bishop s' which actually
helps white
in this position because he is ahead and
development and he gets to make some
pretty serious threats faster than black
and can you know counter them the first
you know move is Queen to f3 attacking
the rook in the corner and you know
gaining more time you can gain time on
the Queen by putting you know your
Bishop on f4 and this is why this
variation is just so nice for white now
after the simple exchange
you can play d5 and again we see that
the d5 break just crushed black here
this is a very very bad position for
black so this line is almost unplayable
people will find different ways to play
it so it's not you know dart dart some
ways you can try to play with the move
b5 but that was not one of them alright
so instead Bishop to g4 is a the main
move here black is playing against the
d4 pawn so this Bishop now is attacking
one of the defenders of d4 and will even
see him you know put a knight on c6 and
castle to bring a rope to the D file and
so the his opening plan is to put a lot
of pressure on the center immediately so
as indicated and after some some normal
moves White has to make a decision here
and he can think about h3 he could think
about d5 the most common is d5 and again
there are two moves here and one is
safer than the other the most common is
Knight to e5 but it should also be
mentioned that night to b4 is a really
sharp variation that both players should
know if they're if they're going to play
this we can do something kind of funny
here though after you kick the bishop
back and it is best not to give away the
bishop for the knight and give away the
light squares because this will be a
really sharp variation and which funny
little trick is he attacks the Queen and
then you attacks her again so he got two
III with tempo and alright so some
reasons that people don't like to play
this at the top level is if white is you
know wants to be boring he's higher
rated or he's a lot lower rated than you
and he just wants to draw you know he
can try to repeat and you have to play
an inferior move if you want to get out
of the repetition so that's one you know
reason that puts people off with a queen
d6 line but some people are happy with
the draws black alright but we'll see
white try to play for a win here and now
we're following a game between
impossible to pronounce names this is a
P order dobra Walski versus yosik Thomas
luck yeah I had no chance but but you
can see it down below
alright so we got some some normal moves
instead of this variation black decided
to play Knight to e5 and blacks approach
is a little bit different here he's
going to rely on trading lots of pieces
in liquidation to try to go into a
favorable endgame so we see this much
different approach and initially white
gets a lot of pressure so black can take
on f3 you can actually start by taking
with either piece it leads to the same
thing and now we've got to deal with the
fact that our queen is attacked and the
most common way is to play e5 we got to
get our Bishop out of course white
should be pretty happy after this
exchange because the Queen is on an open
e file so you know you're going to gain
some more time
so after such moves black is you know
really playing with fire here he's got
some pins White's going to be able to
make a lot of threats initially but if
black is able to just continue to deal
with the threats and trade lots of
pieces again he's going to have a good
chances in the endgame so what do you
drool I can i top that says his dream
endgame and that's what we'll see today
okay so the point of this move is white
is threatening to win a piece so you got
to protect your Bishop with the pond and
okay now both players I mean they didn't
play the most accurate moves here both
of these these moves are all fine and
now yeah black you know make some some
Queen moves that are not necessarily the
best
but we'll see this exchange and you know
it's a very important exchange that
you're making you're giving up a bishop
for a night so this better be you know
pretty good for you
is this night going to emerge as a
better piece than the bishop well after
this move white actually goes into a
mistaken endgame here
he shouldn't trade the rooks he should
play any other move that doesn't trade
it you should move your rook somewhere
but he allows this trade and now white
is getting a lot of pressure immediately
the knight is coming in to f3 and it's
kind of funny here after king h1 you
have no useful discoveries but that's a
pretty good night and after the Queen
trade this is simply a winning endgame
for black the problem is after Knight to
e5 you don't really have time to save
this pawn which means you're going to
lose upon because if you allow me to go
here I'm attacking your bishop and
wherever your Bishop moves you're losing
this pawn so immediately you're already
losing the pawn and who would have
thought that the isolated D pawn would
be trouble so okay so he moves the
bishop and again we just see some nice
technique in the endgame is it's not an
endgame class it's an opening class but
again we see a position where black has
a better minor piece and a more active
King and he proceeds to win another pawn
this was a pretty nice maneuver and now
he's threatening to both trade the
bishops and then he'll have more pawns
in the endgame so that would be a simple
win so you can't you know move the pawn
you just that would just be losing so he
has to move his bishop losing another
pawn and yeah he he didn't didn't try
very much longer
so again yeah we saw a much different
approach for black in that game he he
went for liquidation and it really
worked so again so this is an example of
a solid way to play you get rid of a lot
of the pieces and you play the endgame
so I would like to know what you guys
think out there
the Scandinavian is it solid is it sharp
is it suspicious what do you guys think
just keep sending in your your openings
that you want to see maybe I'll pick
your your favorite one next time hit
like subscribe tweet tumblr all those
other things
whatever Digg is do that do all the hit
all the buttons and I'll see you guys
next week